welcome to another edition of a beginner
breakdown I am your host Mike Hummer
today we'll be going over games from the
Unrated beginner tournament for adults
okay so in the first round the gingo has
white against shawl he starts out pawn
to d4 controlling the pivotal be five
square
so black counters with d5 preventing
white from playing pawn to e4 okay so
white brings out his knight to f3 black
counters Knight to f6 at white plays h3
he really doesn't want this Bishop God
in there
so alright so some players have their
own style so it's not the most
aggressive move but now he doesn't have
to worry about anybody happened to g4 so
black sees that White's playing
defensively so he decides to play
offensively
alright so c5 so white protects it with
c3 so just take take back okay so far so
good
and now E six the dreaded East six move
okay when you play e6 just so boxing in
your bishop why do you do that don't do
that all right so now he gets his Bishop
out of the pawn chain but now black
plays Chuck
alright so white has a couple different
ways to block the check your play as
night here night here night here Bishop
back are the worst Queen there but he
decides to block with the night here
okay so it should black capture this
night no we never want to capture
protected pieces we want to attack them
okay so he decides not to attack you
they place a Nathan there
and now white plays III now black and
still you still got a chance to attack
the pin piece so he plays okay night
attacks the night okay might not be very
good but he wants to attack it so white
is sick of this pin okay he doesn't like
that he's in a pin so he's got to try to
get rid of this pin so he attacks it
with a three it's like go away so he's
like okay check Knight takes so now
black gets the pin back on Queen to a5
but white has a very easy way to get out
of this penny plays b4 okay so in this
position it's pretty much even okay the
materials even everything's even so
white just attacked blacks Queen so we
don't need to make it any more
complicated than it needs to be my
Queens under attack let's retreat at the
safety okay either to b6 or here now
black gets a little bit antsy he's like
okay he just attacked my queen maybe
I'll attack his Queen unfortunately that
doesn't work out so well for him because
I could just take the Queen and then
I'll take and then I'll take back and
I'm down a piece you see how I have one
two three four five pieces and black
only has four okay that means you're
losing okay so so there's no reason to
do anything like oh he attacked my queen
I'm gonna attack his or something it's
like if you can just get out of the
threat go for it okay just retreat the
Queen okay so unfortunately black plays
Knight to c3 and believe it or not he
doesn't even take his Queen he just
calmly moves his queen up out of danger
and note
blacks queen is still in danger so he's
got to move the queen he tries the
sneaky move Queen to a4 hoping that he
takes a knight takes back but white
doesn't fall for it
it's that he just takes the free piece
okay all right so black castles out of
danger that day it was in much danger
and now white is ahead material so you
went to trade pieces and he forces the
Queen trade there's no where this Queen
could go without leading to its demise
so he has to take it so Knight takes f5
Knight jumps up Brooke Brooke over
protects so whites ahead a piece so all
he has to do is limit blacks counter
play and he'll be in business here rook
c1 black choose the night away but
that's okay a5 so black is trying to
open up some files and get some play
here Knight takes Knight jumps into e5
so black plays Knight to c4
unfortunately one two three guys on them
you only got one protector so that's no
good and now black plays something kind
of funny here like if you were playing
black here what would you play yeah rook
takes a three right just take it right
all right and then you have this past
pawn and stranger things have happened
as we see in chess and Steady's decides
instead of taking the pun he'll attack
the protected bishop and it's like one
it's a bad idea anyway
and secondly what can white do to just
crush black now anybody so take a look
look at his last move for this rook
kind of down by your pieces where it can
be easily attacked and if we can attack
it and attack another piece
simultaneously okay so does anybody have
any guesses over there what weight
should do bishop the be five fork the
bishop for good attacks the two rooks
and then it's like oh that's game okay
not the black but black should have just
taken a three and then you know tried
tried his best at you know if white
castles or something try to get his rook
behind the pawn and March start marching
that pawn obviously you don't want to
play your rook to b8 because the bishop
would get it but you get the idea you
know if you play it it's just start
pushing that pawn and just hope good
things might happen you never know you
never know
alright so so that was one game from the
beginner tournament the next game I got
to play a beginner even though I'm too
too high seeded to play in the beginner
tournament sometimes I act like it so
since I was playing in the beginner
tournament I decided maybe I maybe I'll
just play like a beginner on purpose
alright alright so in this I got the
black pieces so we'll flip the board
here alright so white plays out
efore I played the Sicilian defense so
white plays d3 okay you know what I feel
about this move right block in your
Bishop no reason to do that you have an
express way out okay just play Bishop to
c4 or something so d3 Knight to c6 so
now that he clogged up that yeah and did
you notice in that last game deb-deb
bishop on c8 never moved okay but this
is a new game so so he decides I'm gonna
get that that Bishop on f1
out so night up three g6 so he's got to
play g3 to get them out now okay so I
feeling kettle my bishop he fan ko says
Bishop putting it on this long diagonal
dip okay so d6 the reason why I played
e6 in this position is because if I play
Knight up six Y can play e5 and then my
knight has to move and I'm not happy
about it okay that's why I prepare my
moves with d6 somehow
alright d6 so each castles Bishop to g4
I put the night in a pen
alright this is very very important even
though we're making fun of the last guy
in the last game for playing this move
this position it actually is good what
should white play in this position okay
obviously doesn't that one his knight to
be in a pin like this right so what
should black play to say hey I don't
want this pin get out of here
okay h3 good h3 attacks and then I'd
have to retreat or or take if I take
white action might take with the Queen
and he'll be very happy here
okay he doesn't he's not in a pen his
LightSquared bishop is here here here to
stay obvious I got maybe this name move
over here but might even if I hit play
that never with some fine no big deal
and then you could kick it out next move
so yeah good things were happening I
would probably play I would probably
play my bishop just back and that's no
good either
okay I don't even know what I play if he
played h3 okay so so that's what I
needed to play and say it plays Knight
to c3
so you see he's not reacting to any of
blacks moves he's just like well I just
want to get pieces off the back row it
doesn't matter what you do okay so you
have to you have to think alright and
now you're like Mike you can take this
night and get double pawns
it took me years and years and years to
figure this out but I don't want that
even though double pawns as a weakness
for him now this this light squared
bishop will just dominate me okay this
dark square bishop the dark square
bishop would just come in and just rule
and now I can't even Castle or if he if
he lets me castle all right say
something like this castle now he can
just dominate me okay so I need that
dark square bishop to solidify my castle
okay so I would never want to trade this
bishop for this night even if it gives
them double pawns everybody understand
that it's going to hold my whole
position together okay all right so so I
play Queen to d7 so now my Queen and
Bishop are in a battery you know they're
on the same diagonal so now I'm heading
right toward h3 now in this position h3
would be a horrible move for white
because I can just take it for free okay
so it's too late for him to play h3 so
he decides to get out of this pin by
playing Queen to d2 not advisable black
crude play Bishop to h6 but I don't
really want to trade this bishop for his
bishop so I don't want to do that so I
just want to go ahead with my own plant
and play Bishop to h3
okay so Knight to e2 all right so I want
to go on an attack okay I like to just
try to win here so I play h5 probably
not the best move because I know we just
play Knight to e2 to play Knight to f4
so maybe I should have tried to stop it
with a 5 or something but II 5 would
give my opponent this this hole on d5
for night maybe night there and the
night here and then he's got this great
hole for the night alright so I did
that's why I don't play e5 so I go
straight for the the attack with h5 all
right and he plays c3 stopping my knife
from getting up here so I just proceed
with the playing h4 alright so so he
takes with the night and so since I'm in
an adult beginner tournament I'm gonna
take this and take and I'm gonna play
hope chess okay so I've got to play
Queen here hoping he resigns okay but
there's there's two different ways
y can get out of this Queen takes g7
Queen takes G to checkmate can you tell
me that actually there's three and I
didn't even see this third one until
until I was analyzing the game later
so there's actually three ways y can
stop checkmate I was banking that he
didn't see any of them and of course I
was wrong alright so let's let's hear
some answers what what what's the first
way he cannot stop this checkmate
because Queen takes g2 is imminent
anybody got any guesses all right Knight
to g3 that's one alright so you guys see
how that breaks the connection all right
so that's one what else we got Knight f4
which which I bet it's gonna be played
all right which is good because it's it
forces the bit because I can't just
retreat my queen or else bye-bye
Bishop Knight seal okay and then there's
one other crazy way that I didn't even
analyze I have no idea if you're gonna
play if here what it touched touch this
piece I like yep my hope chest worked so
let's just pretend he touches this Queen
and I'm like also
happy that I got oh I got checkmate yep
you didn't you couldn't you couldn't
figure out but there's a funny way this
Queen can actually stop this checkmate
anybody maybe at home this Queen can
stop checkmate believe it or not Queen
here doesn't doesn't pay the bills
Queen to g5 an x-ray so it's pretty cool
pretty cool cuz every plays I just take
that would have been none the wiser okay
so oh okay so he picks a the most
predictable move Knight to f4 with the
fork pretty protects the bishop the
squared the pivotal g2 Square and
attacks the bishop so I have to take
Knight takes interesting okay so so we
have an interesting comment here so
after Knight f4 I'm thinking so his
suggestion is Bishop to h6 I'm thinking
I'm not thinking I was thinking illegal
moves
what about f3 in this position so you
see what we're doing we're trying to
remove the guard
okay the knight is the guard of the
pivotal g2 square so if we can remove
the guard we can take take the dude all
right so so good we have a very
prestigious member in the audience right
now Grandmaster been feingold yes so so
let's say after f3 way i have to take
either the well i can't take their so
been fine go well you just consider you
I guess I would just take here yep
alright so so that's why Bishop to h6
will not be the winning move for black
here alright so Knight to f4
so Bishop takes you to they takes you to
so now black tries to get the fork in
Knight to f3 check forking the king and
the Queen so how would we stop this from
occurring are we just gonna let it
happen
okay up you're just too good
anybody got any idea so so what white
tries to do is uh he just concedes a
pawn just just to make sure that it
doesn't happen all right so Queen to h3
now two players are attacking this pawn
and and now black is kind of threatening
a checkmate here if if white just skips
here Knight to f3 check one legal move
for the King and now you see how this
Queen is protecting checkmate
so what move is black gonna play to put
the hard on anybody got any ideas
because if this Queen would leave this
diagonal there you go Bishop to e5 and
the Queen's under attack he moves away
checkmate okay all right so let's see if
white can actually see this that's why
if you're a higher rated player and
playing somebody bad you don't really
want to trade pieces okay you want it
you want to try to keep on the attack as
much as you can to make it complicated
and tough for him because if he doesn't
see if he just plays
and a move you got him okay so white
plays f3 here okay
that stops the moves so Knight takes D 3
so the queen is now under attack
so Queen better move Queen to e3 so he
protects it alright so so now in this
position white really doesn't like that
this Knights hanging out in his camp
okay it's a burden for him he was like
nothing more to get rid of this Knight
so he picks a really bad way to try to
get rid of this Knight then it ends up
losing his rook if you can believe it
alright but what's a simple way to get
rid of this Knight anybody got any
guesses it's a fork so if we can attack
this night and somebody else with one of
our pieces will be in good shape
oh my god any guesses who can attack
this night of obviously we can play rook
takes and take but we don't want to
trade a five point piece for a three
point piece right obviously he's not
gonna take on c1 here so do we have any
ways to attack this night Jonathan
Knight f4 yeah attacks the Queen and the
night so then you know I just have to
take and now my Knights not up in your
camp or anything okay so that would have
been a good idea instead he tries to uh
to remove the defender removed the guard
of the knight isn't a bad idea but now
Bishop takes the pawn and I still
doesn't like this Knight so bad he's
gonna just let me take and now I got the
rook
and it yeah yeah not bad idea idea all
right when there was a much easier way
to get rid of that night and if you
really
he might be overestimating the strength
is this night anyhow I mean I true it's
way up in his territory but it's not
really doing too much all right so then
retreat the bishop and threaten Queen
takes pawn check so this this is a is a
very obvious way to get out of this
predicament
nobody can guard this so you just need
to break the connection between the
bishop and the pawn he decides the trade
the bishops I get a little cute here
play rook to d8 he doesn't fall for it
and so now he threatens to take this
bishop for free because if I play some
random move Bishop takes if I take pawn
checkmate okay sweet yeah so I see it so
I I take it Knight takes and now I get
this meaningless H pawn okay
so white is doing pretty good
considering he's a beginner here
does anybody have any suggestions what
moves he might play right now they don't
have to be good they don't have to be
bad his Knights under attack so it could
just move it okay try to threaten check
I don't know what that would do but but
you know you just getting your pieces in
a aggressive territory and good things
are bound to happen okay so now black
plays Knight f6 finally getting his last
piece into the game and this is where he
falls apart unfortunately so in this
position obviously you could just take
check and you know 1 2 3 4 5 he
down upon in a queen and rook endgame
but he decides to do a pawn break so you
have the C pawn or the e pawn which one
do you want to break with there's a big
difference between them so if you had to
move your C pawn or you're a pawn which
one would you want to do all right
so unfortunately my opponent plays d5
Omega blunder yeah fortunately for me
yes unfortunate for him so so it looks
like he's doing great he's attacking my
knight and so forth but it's very
vulnerable obviously if I take here he's
very very happy Knight takes check pawn
takes checkmate okay Wow yeah so luckily
I see it and I also see that I can start
being an aggressive player so the most
aggressive move is check so does anybody
see a good check for black you guys see
some checks for black hopefully there's
only one check that doesn't actually
lose his coin so let's just go with that
one Queen to h5 unfortunate doesn't g4
that's the g5 wherever all right Queen
to GF I check Forks the king and the
pawn and unfortunately he's like oh I
just get out of check yeah but he really
needed to pay attention where he was
going to get out of check here because
if he plays King to f1 here after I take
the pawn here I have no checks with my
queen you see
no checks okay and now what can I then
what can a white play to maybe hurt me
here anybody got any ideas
besides Grandmaster been Feingold do you
see a Jonathan so he wants me to just
attack the Queen back like yeah all
right been silent the producer sees a
rook to e1 alright so so this is kind of
scary for black and luckily I didn't
have to go look think about this
variation cuz he played a queen to g5
Chuck he played King f2 so I saw okay
this is easy when I take take what do
you think Grandmaster been fungal if he
were to play King to f1 okay thank you
so so yeah where would happen is I take
the knight first then he'd take anyway
he takes back then I'll take the off
pawn okay so so I wasn't too concerned
but it just made it so I didn't have to
think so now when I take you now he
plays rook to e1 it doesn't have the
same bite because I take with Czech and
it's hopeless check yeah and then you
just you just trade Queens take the
coward's way out it's it's no big deal
now I have one two three four five six
bonds to his three I really like my
chances especially when he plays King to
eat - I keep my rook active he's got
passive rook and it's now it's just a
matter of time and then when he plays
this move I just humiliate him wow what
move does black black played at
humiliate him cuz he's like oh he's
remove the guard of my rook but I have a
really cool move here that would be
great yeah yeah so Ben Pangos says the
most humiliating way it's just a place
Jack King takes and then just just win
anyway so in this position I play that
and then his spirit is broken and games
over so those were the games from the
adult beginner tournaments we do have
some bonus games to show you though so
we'll get to those here okay some bonus
yeah I wanted can you pull it all right
well we're mandatory to go over a game
where somebody plays f6 so we'll show
you how bad f6 is once again all right
flip the board here all right so white
plays d4 black plays 'if I've Knight f3
knight c6 d4 okay so this is the scotch
game so black decides to play f6 in this
position okay still not a good move okay
so pawn takes pawn takes Bishop the c4
attacks this pivotal f7 square here and
now black further weakens his light
squares with h6 okay he really needed to
get in the move Knight f6 to have any
kind of chance but when he plays h6 now
he can you just go ahead and capture
Knight takes Queen check forking the
king and the night and I can't go back
to f7 or else it's checkmate
g6 is still pretty bad okay if he plays
King e7 not recommended checkmate
alright so so the way black out in all
this trouble is on this third movie
played f6 so please don't play f6
alright got it
alright so g6 Queen takes check forking
the king and the Queen Queen takes so he
gets a check in here but Bishop e2 night
e7 so he takes here bishops in a pin
threatening checkmate and then so
there's only one way for black the stop
this checkmate I believe well well well
there might be there might be another
one but what's the best way for black
just try to stop this checkmate here so
Ben just like just resign just give it
all up but what else we got here how can
we stop this Queen takes checkmate
anybody got any ideas or did we just tip
it
so black keeps I mean here is a plan for
about 40 more moves unfortunately we
don't have to see all 40 of the moves
but but he's still east
yeah Queen to f5 yep and then see how
that protects the guys so he's like all
right whatever and now he's got one two
three four pieces
he's got three one two three four five
pawns so I'm up a pawn and a rook so
this is all my profit over here so it
should be a pretty easy way to win here
okay so so so in when you're playing the
opening stay away from f6 all right e4
e5 Knight f3 knight c6 d4 never a good
idea never okay just take whatever don't
play f6 alright so now we got a game a
Julian he's just back from Ohio just
camp okay so he's he's feeling pretty
good he got some lessons with our
resident grandmaster of oracle bein so
he's feeling pretty strong okay so he's
got the white pieces against Chess Club
champion Preston Smith but the champ
quote-on-quote champ
d4 d5 blazes uh plays this pawn out so
black plays Knight f6 protects the pawn
all right Knight to c3 now he brings the
other night out so he brings the other
night out so they got all the Knights
going so now Bishop the g4 alright so
white besides play Knight to e5 it's not
in a pin so now he attacks
the guy so he decides to retreat us
Bishop to e6 not a very good square for
this Bishop here yep yep
you called yeah so now his pawn can't
move and this Bishop is looking like a
really big pawn all right yep so yeah I
mean pressing you probably wanted to get
castled eventually but this wasn't the
way to go about it so white plays III
Knight takes e5 pawn takes d5 Knight
goes the g4 attacking this pawn because
it was yeah
yes is everybody here what Ben Feingold
said don't play Knight takes e5 in this
position cuz uh now when this pawn
retreats we have one one two three
attackers of d5 and he's only got two
and now we'll get our massive pawn pawn
center here and we're gonna suffocate
this guy here so he decides to go all
the way back home with this bishop oh my
gosh alright so so now it plays the
check so now if he plays Bishop to g7 or
Knight hangs yeah yeah yeah I saw
something before the grandmaster well
pile at the same time alright so fish up
the b5 so I guess he's got to play c6 so
he does so now Julian takes and he's
like okay well I'll take a check take
the Queen with check now if you're white
how would you take back anybody got any
ideas
cuz there's two ways to take back this
is very important
it's important to me how would you take
back you could take with the king which
would be bad or you could take with a
knight and protect f2 all right and now
preston doesn't know what to do
sorry decides to play rook the b8 double
question mark so how does Julian put the
final touches on this beauty so all you
have to do is find your one check and
you can play like Julian there's only
one check on this entire board there
actually is two checks so so one check
is a thousand times better than the
other one so let's find out the good
check its axle we push the pawn and it's
checkmate the discovered checkmate King
can't go there
wow it's not even made unbelievable in
the game they thought it was checkmate
and then we take the rook yeah we will
promote to a Brooke for all the fans in
the audience and that's the knight would
lose the best show so make sure to tune
in next week as we'll have a spectacular
spectacular lecture